hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan the wright and my name is jerry
the jerry welcome
to our show
called reasons to see we give you
reasons
to see but you've all heard of this
movie there's not gonna be any reasons
not to see uh the movie's called gravity
by the way
so we're gonna hang out and talk about
this [ __ ]
reason to see number one
directing in cinematography
i [ __ ] love this film right off the
bat first thing i noticed the
cinematography the direction
okay like i don't want to ruin [ __ ]
about this film for you guys i don't
want to go into details about anything
when you keep it short and simple
it's [ __ ] beautiful all of it a lot
of the shots are like long tracking
shots that are smooth as ever damn is it
beautiful especially on imax 3d that is
the way to [ __ ] go if you can't go
imax go on 3d
i would say at least 3d because this is
one of the very few movies where i'm
like 3d is awesome for this experience
there's just no way you can get the
experience of this movie
from watching it at home like the way
it's meant to be experienced watch this
movie on your ipod find the biggest
screen possible make sure it's 3d
because this movie is a sensory
experience just as much as it is
you know a story and it really does feel
like it was shot in space like they
really innovated in the way that they
chose to shoot this movie so that you
really feel like you're there the whole
time which is very stressful it doesn't
do any hollywood beating around the bush
[ __ ] no it is like oh they're in you
know they're on earth and here's their
backstory and here's all the people
they're going to leave behind and oh no
what if they don't make it it just
starts off in space it's it's
a real-time journey yeah what i love
about it is it's got so many different
themes that are being communicated just
to the visual experience it's that rare
film where the visual feast is like part
of the true raw substance of this film
that creates such an emotion for you
it's not just beautiful to look at like
the way it's all captured it's haunting
at the same time it's scary you're also
in admiration adoration about like wow
yeah
it can be beautiful sometimes and i
sometimes don't ever want to go to space
actually i don't ever want to go to sp
this movie just further solidifies this
is one of this is going on my list of
those movies that aren't horror movies
but that are really scary yeah cause
they're like they're just fixing a
spaceship they're they're not going to
like oh we heard about something in the
distant far part of the universe they're
right outside verse 3 or anything like
that
it feels like a fantasy but it also
feels so real at the same time it's
immersive it's a very lyrical sort of
sensory experience it's a very sort of
like i think you use the word poetic
it's poetry man it does have this is a
movie that has to be
a film like there's no other way
that they could they couldn't have
translated this into any different art
form this is a truly a movie it's a
visual experience just as much as any of
the other elements come in you know
they're pushing the boundaries of cinema
forward and telling both a very
immediate but also very human story yeah
especially at first because you're kind
of wondering to yourself like what what
is this movie really about it is about
survival it you know it's and it really
explores like you have to dig deep in
yourself just to do all that you know
and it's about really finding yourself
in order to see like how bad you want to
live like there's so much of these like
oh it's
i don't want to give anything away it's
it's so [ __ ] just watch it it's kind
of like a better version of after earth
what kind of because he's walking her
through this [ __ ] and then she has to do
it on her own and then like oh yeah it's
going wrong
sorry i was thinking like after earth
has like space creatures yeah i don't
know i'm saying like just the amount on
some of the thematic oh and there's
black people and after
yeah there's an indian or there there is
a like a
middle eastern guy
who i thought was cliff curtis but
wasn't reason to see number two
visual effects
have you ever heard the word spectacular
well you have now that is the word to
describe this it is scrum true lesson
scrum true lesson anyway we're talking
about visual effects
visual effects like we said just
it's it's an orgasm on string it is and
and part of what's so great about it too
is is like they always say the best
visual effects are always the ones you
can't tell are there and there is so
much of this movie where i'm sitting
around going i know there are a lot of
visual effects here and i can't tell
what exactly is it is you know yeah
constructed what's not just right it
feels like you're in space you know yeah
it feels like all this pay attention it
brought space to life especially on imax
it's it feels like an imax documentary
camera like
you know just went into space and this
horrible thing happened sorry for all
the weird metaphors but it's almost like
watching a really great magic trick
because you know that there's something
at work but you just can't tell where
that sleight of hand is sorry with all
the metaphors
but it's kind of like
the first time you bite into a french
fry dipped in mcdonald's barbecue sauce
yeah that's the visual effects reason to
see number three
sandra bullock
[ __ ]
there's one [ __ ] in this movie yeah it
was at the right time yeah it was great
great great writing by the way it's not
a category on this but it should be
here's what i got to say about this the
writing i think was good but what really
made the writing even like 10 times
better was sandra bullock's performance
that woman was really in outer space
okay it was like that raw of a
performance you know you really believe
like there's a lot of not only you know
emotional stuff but there's a lot of
like physical just the toll this
experience is taking on her and with all
these fluid camera motions and you know
invisible cuts and stuff like that it
really does feel like she's just going
through all this in real time so it's it
kind of puts they really put you in her
shoes it's kind of like playing a video
game in a way she's the avatar for you
you know and you're just experiencing
the craziest space nightmare through her
shoes like this had to be a pretty heavy
undertaking for her as an actress
because like she's using pure
imagination totally world of pure
imagination
but it's pure imagination and it's like
she's totally buying everything she's
just fantasizing up in her brain right
now well yeah and also i mean on the
other side of things you know the
writing what's cool about this movie is
you know it's not overly written in the
sense that there isn't there's dialogue
but there's not a huge amount of
dialogue and she brings a lot to the
rich material that she's given you get
to learn about this character through
seeing how she deals with struggles
that's all i'm going to say i don't want
to give away anymore reason to see
number four
george clooney
the cloon it's like george clooney
playing george clooney as an astronaut
and it is magnificent i imagine the
script probably read like you know uh
what's his name
his name is
matt something
does it really matter kowalski there you
go kowalski handsome george clooney type
yeah because you know is it george
clooney time only george clooney could
have played this role yeah i made it or
he's so natural in the performance he's
not just mr charming guy you know
there's times where you know [ __ ] gets
intense really intense and george
clooney gets a little intense and let's
see what george clooney does and how his
character is but it's it's definitely a
good suit compared to
sandra bullock yeah well yeah exactly
they play off each other really well not
not to get too deep into it but their
positions are very different yes as far
as this mission goes and it's a nice you
know interplay between them because of
that yeah like my favorite moments were
actually with with them when they're
going back and forth it's funny because
there's not a [ __ ] ton of that but
there's just enough of that and it's
it's just everything's about this just
perfect it's the
perfect film and he's still handsome and
charming as ever he doesn't age anymore
no he doesn't he just drinks the blood
of children and and stays youthful
forever reason to see number five
the score
musical yeah
gravity gravity we're gonna be floating
in space please copy please please count
if you're interested in the score
because of the fact that this is a
category and you haven't seen the movie
yet do not go on youtube and look up the
score save it for the movie because it
is
perfect but this is an example of a
movie where every element really hooks
into every other element it's like
everything works so synchronously to
make one complete picture everything is
really composed to be complementary so
the music is great and there's a lot of
different sounds there's some really
dramatic stuff there's some really
beautiful stuff there's some really sort
of you know textural stuff you know some
things are electronic some things are
more organic instruments you know
orgasm orgasm music i want to make love
to that music make babies to that music
huh that would be a really intense while
my woman is in labor that music is going
to be playing
yeah
i think it'd be cool to have a baby in
space and just watch it float away
that would be very jarring that'd be sad
be kind of funny it'll happen too
spacex exists you know now space is
privatized in america so like i'm sure
someone's gonna have a space baby at
some point
space baby space baby babies in space
reason to see number six
sound design
go on imax
experience it or go into a good theater
the sounds are bigger it's uh
there's it's it's
take it away
i mean say it again everything in this
movie is important like every part of
the technical story all that stuff they
all meld together to create one
experience and sound is such a big part
of this movie the first thing they
remind you of is that in space there is
no sound or something carry sound and
they really play with that the whole
time so depending on where they are and
what's going on they've really warped
certain sounds and it's very selective
with what you can hear and you know it's
one of those rare movies where it's not
distracting but you do notice like wow
they put a lot of thought into the
design and the mixing of all these
sounds and it's really seamless sound is
supposed to be like
not noticeable when you notice sound
that might be a bad sign except for this
movie you notice sound because it's like
sound is very important because none of
this is real but it all looks real
ryan's consensus gravity
is the reason
movie theaters are made gravity is the
reason movie theaters are made this is a
film that you can only truly experience
in the cineplex jerry's consensus
gravity is the reason i will never go to
space gravity is the reason jerry will
never go to space but seriously though
this is a this is a reason movies are
made film it really immerses you it's a
it's a very sensory experience and plus
you can really feel like there was a lot
of passion a lot of innovation that went
into it and that's what
cinema is all about all right guys
thanks for checking out our review for
gravity why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below and tell us
who would you have a baby with in space
and once you're done with that come on
over here there's a button
and uh when you click it there's more
episodes of reasons to see so go check
that out
there are more episodes i'm sorry
there's poor grammar yeah [ __ ] after
you're done with that why don't you go
ahead follow us on twitter
and follow us on facebook
i gotta check that twitter again i
haven't once in a while yeah it's a it's
uh
we need more friends yeah we do
hey
and if you guys are truly our friends
once you're done liking our facebook and
following our twitter
you're going to want to get updated
every time a new reviewer video is out
right so we can hang out more so if
that's the case
you're gonna wanna
subscribe hell yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
we just called our friends a [ __ ] yeah
but like in the in the friendly kind of
[ __ ] way oh okay yeah you know it's a
new word for homie yeah it really is and
it's kind of jarring to me when
when you know chicks are just like oh
that [ __ ] oh yeah she's like my main
[ __ ] and i'm like
i get it now yeah i get how weird this
is you never notice like no dudes are
like yeah that guy's my dick right there
that's my dick
you know it's like guys say like that's
my boy or whatever
but various other she's not saying
that's my [ __ ] over there
i guess but
but you can call a guy a dick in the
same way you would call a girl a [ __ ]
it's like a derogatory term you know
what you know what that's a fair point
that's a fair point
thank you
you know this movie does makes you
appreciate earth
it does makes you go i never want to
[ __ ] leave this place i love being
here
i love gravity
yeah i love you know
inertia yeah that's the way i think the
message of this film was to get you to
appreciate gravity i love centrifugal
force we used to be like oh i wish i
could fl well you know if we could fly
yeah every every pop song is about
flying and touch the skying and then
like every time you see a space movie
you're like [ __ ] that i don't want to
stay on the ground you know i can never
wave my hands like i just don't know
because like what if i hit somebody run
and runner came out this weekend it did
and
no one saw it i've heard justin
timberlake while not amazing is not
anywhere near as bad as the trailer
makes him look like he isn't yeah i
remember when people thought he was just
like gay yeah now when he had that curly
fro thing yeah i was in his part and
sing now he's like respected yeah and
well because you know and i think he's a
good actor too he's an artist
he's good at what he does yeah
i want to rock our body please stay
that's a wow
it just occurred to me because he just
put out the second half of his new album
and i didn't realize that sexy back is
like seven years old wow we are old yeah
that song is as old as a small child
or like a moderately sized child yeah i
like just sexy back
to my boys
you